KV is winning what I know winning that
was my reaction as well when I heard
that Queen and Knight versus queen and
Bishop three versus two yes she is right
what happened there let's take a look
wow what a turnaround that is Anna must
have done something terribly wrong very
wrong okay so first of all this should
be no but go back go back go back go
back King was on King was on H you
played H5 King G1 H4
Bishop H2 oh maybe bishop F2 she didn't
want to play that well but why don't you
want to play this you just take another
of the board uh by the way none of let's
just get the current position because
the current well the current position is
this she's going to pick up this Pawn
okay you don't play Bishop C3
immediately but you do play Bishop B4
you do play Bishop A3 one day you attack
the Knight and then you pick up the pawn